in spiritual formation there's something
called Dark Night of the Soul now I
never experienced it in spiritual
formation but what it is is when you
just don't hear from God anymore you
join your contemplative prayer but you
don't feel anything anymore like the
Wilderness yeah experience yes yes
[Music]
so Stephanie your chaplain was able to
see into your life spiritually and tell
you things that only you would know
about
he did in his prayer time that's what
God told him that's what he said God
told him huh and only he was able to
tell that because he was a man of God is
that what he said yes so you grew up in
a
spiritual home or was it a Christian
home or how did you grow up we grew up
initially as a Christian we were
attached to a church we belong to a
church but we didn't really go much
until I was five
and then my parents my mom became
Seventh-day Adventist and we started
going to church from there
consistently and so you found all this
spiritual formation in The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church well no not then
um I was working in a hospital and
though I was working at a denominational
hospital I was also Moonlighting
for a community hospital and that's
where I ran into a a Nazarene chaplain
for the hospital
okay who was a spiritual director he was
a spiritual director of the hospital and
he um when he was the chaplain of the
hospital and within spiritual formation
you can become a spiritual director
and that's what he had taken on so he
had become
a spiritual director okay but you can
find that in all religions now
and he just randomly came up to you I
feel like there's a backstory yeah we
had we had um I had known this man I had
been Moonlighting at this facility for
about seven years and he was so kind
he's like the grandfatherly type very
kind very personal and so wherever
wherever I was be it ER ICU and he knew
I was there he would come and find me
Stephanie how are you doing oh what's
going on in your life and he didn't want
to just say oh you know here okay I'm
good you know how are you doing it was
like no how are you
where is God stirring the waters in your
life
he wanted he was very real
and so he wanted to know
um but he would from time to time invite
me
to
meet with him once a month
as a spiritual friend to see what God
was doing in my life
well I didn't know what spiritual
Direction was at that time
it was I didn't even know what spiritual
formation was
I had just come back to my faith into a
relationship with Christ
and because of
um
a very hurtful situation at the time
with my family I was angry with God
and I told him get out of my life I
don't want anything to do with you which
is very dangerous yeah I would advise
anybody to do that essentially as a
nurse I had no code order on my life do
not resuscitate because God can't do
what we he does what we don't want him
to do
so but
fast forward a couple of years later
my grandfather was dying in the hospital
and my family called me and said if you
want to see your grandfather again you
need to come home now and he may not be
alive when you get here I had a two-hour
drive home from where I lived
and I got there and I was the very last
person to see him
and he asked me to pray for him and I
couldn't pray for him I was angry with
God and I love my grandfather and he was
very much a Christian man and he was
good to me and I couldn't
say a lie to him so my father came and
prayed with him and then the next
visiting hour
that's when I was the last one to see
him I'm sorry
he I asked him if he wanted to turn over
and he nodded his head
and when I rolled him over the fluids in
his heart shifted and the line went flat
and so
um hearing is the last to go and I just
like grandpa I love you thanks for being
a good grandpa you know but that was a
Divine appointment God was trying to
reach me
I was the only
um
I should say Seventh-day Adventist
grandchild in the family
and I lived right next to him growing up
so we had a nice Bond so we had
connection and
when
I couldn't pray for him that broke my
heart and so I carried this I don't want
to say guilt but heartache
and it was from that time that
experience that
as an ER nurse we have people who die in
the emergency room unfortunately but
it's a fact I didn't want to not be able
to give that gift of prayer for someone
who may be in a similar situation so I
thought in order to pray for somebody I
need to have a relationship with Christ
so I started reading my Bible
and from there a relationship grew
and then I found out about the sanctuary
message which I had grown up in this
religion gone to Seventh-day Adventist
schools never heard the sanctuary
message this message is beautiful and
contains every doctrine that we teach
[Music]
it converted me and it gave me a solid
foundation this is why
um I'm a Seventh-Day Adventist and not
Methodist like I was born into or
another another belief system so you
sacrifice animals now is that
state
so what was it about the sanctuary
messages for our viewers who might not
know I saw Lily transformed you good
question I saw the love of God along
with our Doctrine so it's God's love the
love of Jesus who sacrifice for us and
every step of it you know um the
sacrifice and then his blood that covers
Us and he watches us when we repent he
covers Us and and then he wants to
cleanse us
so it gave reason for the differences
um from the other denominations and I
just felt God's love and I could see the
um
the biblical basis for for all of our
teachings they were Rock Solid you said
that all the termination They Don't
Preach this kind of stuff this message
that is very true because I've been
going to I used to go to different
churches before
and asked questions and he said yeah I
mean we we read it but we don't teach it
anymore and I believe that and that
message of the century message I mean
you can we you know we see salvation you
know but also the beautiful thing is the
and the most holy place that's the Ten
Commandments
and there's a place there the the God
dwells and guy wants to have that
relationship with us yeah intimacy
exactly and then other religions they
don't if you don't preach about the Ten
Commandments God's law God's Eternal law
that I mean what is our fundamental as a
Christian
what is God's ruling our life and who is
God because they are a translation of
his character right so so the the
sanctuary message so I I like I like
that but what what is it about the
sanctuary message that's relevant today
because I've you know I've been to
churches where they say that the Old
Testament was for the old Covenant and
the New Testaments for the New Covenant
and I'm a new testament Christian so I
don't have to worry about that Old
Testament anymore
isn't there something and and so what I
found and this is just the three things
I found maybe you guys have found more
than I have but those three things
inside the holy place the sanctuary
table of show bread Candlelight and the
the incense incense those are the things
that represent a Christian character
Christian Life when you become a
Christian you pray more that's the
incense you read your Bible uh you read
the word of God which is the table of
show bread and the light right the
candlelight is you're sharing the gospel
yes so it's very relevant to our life is
there anything else that you saw that
was like Epiphany to you out of that
that is relevant to a New Testament
Christian
like we are today
um
what do you say oh yeah
we have justification and sanctification
all right there and that's that's what
he's doing wants to recreate Us in His
image baptism is that is that uh labor
or on the outside and the Lamb of God is
Christ that was on the inside and inside
the most holy place is where God keeps
Ten Commandments the The Throne of God
as it was and that Mercy seats Mercy
right I think that's the people the
thing that people forget you know in
terms of New Testament versus Old
Testament God is merciful
and so you know he was merciful in the
Old Testament and he's merciful today
God never changes we like to change his
words but God never changes so I share
that because I I wanted I want to paint
a picture that that was Rock Solid in
our teachings
and then from there
um I was all about prayer right I had
read books on prayer by Glenn ABC's
of Bible prayer Roger Moore know and
learned a lot about prayer so prayer was
very meaningful to me because of where I
had been
so then after a three-day fast in prayer
God moved me to Southern California I'm
a Southern girl from Virginia we don't
leave our family so this was a God thing
but it was after true prayer and true
Bible reading that God moved and so I
remember driving cross country and
praying Lord I don't know why you're
sending me out here but don't let me
mess up
so fast forward this is where I was and
then
um after a few years of being around
this chaplain
and then not seeing him maybe for about
six months and then coming back to this
facility to work he comes to me and he
he does this this is a Quaker way of
praying you hold I'm coming to you this
is what I have today but you're holding
yourself up so it comes to you with this
yeah I'm holding you in prayer oh right
okay so it's just the gestures yeah
nothing in his hands no but they usually
they pray with a candle so they're
holding you up to the Light of Christ
and praying for you wait so I picture
him walking down the hall towards you
with his hands like this is does it look
like you know what that means or what I
didn't at the time but but it was a
natural conversation when I hold you in
prayer this is what I sense
I sense heartache I sense a struggle I
sense
um hurt anxiety and something to do with
a man
wow I'm like he just told me everything
I was feeling and kind of what it
revolved around
so he says now
would you like to meet as a friend once
a month to see what God's doing in your
life
and because I desired a closer
connection with God
I said yes
I would like that if he knew if he was
so close to God that he knew what was
going on in my life I wanted to know
what he knew
it is a very nice invitation it was
beautiful I mean it's not something like
hey beautiful these kind of guy is weird
or anything like that no I mean he comes
up to you sincere and like a grandfather
and that was a grandfather wound right
you go into a relationship with you
before he went to talk to you and the
question is like how he knows all this
stuff yeah I don't
those are very common things that women
deal with
and what they are to tell like like
those were just I don't know they just
sound like very common common themes in
women's lives and probably yeah but you
know there were good relationships too
so but yes I mean you could probably
throw something out and it's going to be
true for somebody somewhere along the
way but those things at this time nailed
it nailed it nailed it nailed it you
know so that to me was validation
that he was a man who was connected to
God and I wanted that kind of connection
so what I didn't understand then was I
was I was being invited to spiritual
Direction
which is
a whole
piece of the spiritual formation
movement
so nine years I began spiritual
formation Journey
and
and you weren't aware you thought it was
I didn't know what it was yeah
um
but after a year
it was very much it was becoming very
much a part of me well the first the
first session actually he taught me
contemplative prayer they gave me
Thomas keating's book on contemplative
prayer and so I read that and I started
engaging in contemplative prayer
um because that was supposed to be the
most intimate place like the sanctuary
in the most holy place that's where you
really commune with God and that's where
he can do his most sacred work cleansing
work and that's what they were teaching
them that's what they teach you Dallas
Willard says it's the um
it's um oh I can basically oh it's
sanctification that's what he calls the
sanctification process right and I was
told it's like the operating room
so that's why they encourage you to
spend as a Christian they encourage you
to spend
lots of time and contemplative prayer so
then after a year of doing this
he extended an invitation he said have
you ever thought of becoming a spiritual
director I'm like well no he said well
there's a discernment process you can go
through
it's about eight months
um it's a course you can take and if
you're interested let me know I said
well I am
so I started taking training for that
and after eight months I decided I do
want to become a spiritual director
director now mind you I had been reading
the Bible I've been engaging in biblical
prayer those things never dropped away
I inserted the silence for if you're
familiar with the mnemonic prey
praise repent ask in yield that silence
I inserted into yield meaning I'm here
listening God what is it you want to
tell me
so
that was a protectant I found out later
that I didn't drop off those things but
I also in addition to the Bible I was
also reading Spirit of Prophecy that
dropped away it's not like oh don't read
that it's like oh here's this read these
readings and they to me for some reason
were so meaningful and beautiful to me
that the the spirit of Prophecy piece
fell away
my Bible reading never did and I praise
God for that and I think those pieces
along with my belief and that when you
die you you are asleep waiting for Jesus
to come back was it protectant
for me how to not hear how well one of
the pieces of the healing
um was my spiritual director
encouraged me to have a conversation
with my dead grandfather imagine
speaking to him about not being able to
pray for him what would he say to you
today
and my thing was you know no way I I
don't believe that he's alive he won't
be speaking to me but someone else would
be right so I'm glad that that door was
never opened because that's part of um
Genesis right Genesis and the snake came
to Eve and said you will not surely die
so that's been the lie that's been told
forever yeah and that
most of Christendom believes
so but as a result I did not have a
spirit guide I did not have things
manifest to me
which I'm grateful if they had because
of what I knew the Bible taught
I would have run right I would have left
all these practices behind but Satan
knows how far to take us
and when to hold back to keep us
entrenched so I thought I was engaging
in biblical prayer and moving forward in
my relationship with God
so together with the first year of
discernment and then the two-year
program for becoming spiritual director
I did two and a half years
and something happened that last year I
just kept I was I was bumping up against
the readings I'm like why can I
understand this now I don't get it and I
would reread and reread and reread and
it was just like I don't understand it
so I withdrew from the program thinking
okay I'm just busy in life
I'll pick this up maybe next semester or
next year and move forward and get this
done God had other plans he put me in
nursing school I changed jobs and I went
back to get my credential for school
nursing and and then my Master's Degree
which was part of that so he diverted me
and then
I still maintain these practices and it
was it was me it was my life I would go
to spiritual Retreats I would spend much
time in contemplative prayer now my
roommate who lived with me
if she would come in and rattle the
dishes or open the door I'd be like oh
you know it would make me so frustrated
so the fruit wasn't there not the fruit
of the spirit from the Bible
from God but there was no growth and she
told me later she's the stuff I saw no
growth in you during that period Well I
didn't know it you know
but that's how it's part of the
deception right we're so busy working
and engaging in something that feels so
good that we don't recognize the other
the other thing is repentance wasn't
there
because conviction never came
when your frontal lobe is offline the
Holy Spirit can't speak to you
so I never felt convicted during this
time
and when I came out the first time I
felt conviction it was overwhelming was
what it was almost at first but I was
grateful for it because God was once
again working in my life
um but anyway so that's where I was and
then my sister came for a visit
and she went back when we had Bible
stores
um she prayed before she went in
and she's like Lord if there's anything
in here that somebody needs lead me to
it
so she went in she was looking at the
books and she just was drawn to this
book on the table and she didn't know
why because she didn't know the content
either so she would go over and pick it
up wasn't on sale
and then put it back down I don't even
know what that is three times she went
over there and she's like I'm just
supposed to get this book so she got the
book and when she came home because I
love to read
um I like let me see what she got so I
emptied the book the books on the floor
and my my eyes went straight to that
book
and I read the back I'm like I'll see
you when I'm done and I went to my room
and it was
um
Rick Howard's book The Omega Rebellion
now he was from the new age
and I was not I was a Christian
I I was convicted on the spiritual
practices but I was not convicted about
um
contemplative prayer because this is how
sneaky the flesh is after all he was new
age he doesn't understand contemplative
prayer Minds biblical
right so I continue the contemplative
prayer but God wasn't finished and he um
somehow and I forget how I got this book
maybe I went to the store then I found
Howard Pratt's book the dangers of
contemplative prayer
and that book convicted me
and I tell you that was a hard book to
read because then I had a decision to
make is this the new age author no this
was a Christian Author okay unpacking
contemplative prayer and the real roots
of it while part of the real Roots was
the name of that book the dangers of
contemplative prayer okay the danger
yeah it's a really good book to get I
don't remember him going into the occult
on it but it's been a while
but
um
so then
then I was faced with a decision am I
going to be obedient
and walk away from this something that's
so meaningful to me where I feel that I
experienced Jesus am I walking away from
God by doing this
so it's
it's fact over feelings right this was a
battle for me personally because I'm a
feeler
so to give this up was from here
um not in my heart you know but it's
like I wanted to honor God and do things
his way
so every day
I had to redecide not to do that that
stuff is addicting it's a dopamine
effect and it's addicting so what does a
feeler do when no longer you experience
this feeling
of warmth and peace and safety
you perceive it to be that right
this was your experience so it must be
and
so there for a while
a short season maybe a couple months or
so
I would just do my typical prayers and
leave off the silence
but I didn't experience anything and I'm
like God are you there did I walk away
from you
it was I wrong on this so when Satan
can't keep us Bound in deception he will
use fear
and anyway I I by the grace of God I
remain faithful to what I believed was
right
and in spiritual formation there's
something called
um
Dark Night of the Soul
now I never experienced it in spiritual
formation but what it is
when you just don't hear from God
anymore you join your contemplative
prayer
but you don't feel anything anymore like
a Wilderness yes yes yes
um I thought
okay so was that the real thing and this
is not this is my Wilderness because you
are not here God
but that's Satan playing tricks right
the truth is when people practice
contemplative prayer it's void of the
holy spirit so they do end up with
a Dark Night of the Soul experience
because it doesn't have the Holy Spirit
but for me
um I feel like this was my time of
testing are you going to be faithful or
are you going to go back
and so by the grace of God I remain
faithful and then after that
my prayers
became powerful it's like I never
experienced this in contemplative prayer
and just for an example I remember
someone called me they were going to
court to defend it was for a major
business
and they were being accused of something
they shouldn't have been accused for of
at all
and we prayed together before they had
to take the stand and my prayer was
for the other person who was wrongfully
accusing
if they don't speak the truth
don't let them speak at all
the person gets up on the stand and he
has a stroke
and he's removed from the courtroom
this is the kind of not that I would
ever wish that on somebody but this is
the kind of power we can walk in when we
are doing biblical prayers when we are
doing things God's way I agree
we have help from above and Satan
doesn't want us to have help
when you apply that to our lives and our
characters
the contemplative prayer is void is not
going to get us anywhere the holy spirit
will transform and change us from the
inside
change our minds
so my mind was bound in contemplative
prayer
for nine years
um
I read a book because I was very
searching God it's called revive us
again by my mark friendly and that
little book is about help you to have a
Revival you know in your own life
and it is a chapter it was about prayer
and I never had the experience he
mentioned about you need to prayer out
loud
and you know before it was just me you
know prayer and quietly or in your mind
and stuff like that but in that chapter
it was talking about prayer out loud
and he was saying he said you will feel
the difference you can see or feel the
difference of
the presence of God and stuff like that
so I was like I'm gonna do that you know
I'm gonna never done it before so I
speak out loud
and it was really really I don't know it
feels very powerful because you keep
talking and just talking and and
it was very interesting because after I
was entering maybe like 15 minutes
praying to God aloud
and I don't really like to share this
stuff maybe like share it but I guess
it's gonna be sharing but
uh it's something like you have like a
like like a GoPro camera
and I was imaginary myself that I was
you know like a camera looking from the
top to the bottom
and
and I was kind of like an imagineering
this and was praying and stuff like that
and I feel something weird
and my hair was going up and I was like
what's going on and I keep praying and I
imaginating that I was praying and
around me it was
evil angel or something like that they
were kind of like look at me and go and
walk around me
and I was just it was kind of like I was
I didn't see it because my audio was
closed and I was just praying and
praying and and I was like just like
please guy help me with it you know kind
of like better out loud
and it was it was for a little
I mean I can think maybe like like for
five minutes but it was a long time
and then
it was I didn't see was I ain't I didn't
see
but it was defeat it was coming down
some
I guess I can sing angel or something
like that but with the wins it went like
this
and those evil guys it was just
disappear
wow so
went about prayer when you talk about
prayer it is powerful if we want to if
we don't want to we don't want to we
will not dedicate time on prayer right
Satan tries to use anything and
everything even counterfeit prayer yeah
right to to Sidetrack us yeah so I don't
know I don't know I haven't studied more
in detail
a loud prayer maybe you know you can
share something like I I should do a
deeper dive into this that's a really
good topic and it has come up a little
bit more lately
um some people say oh you shouldn't pray
out loud because then Satan knows Satan
knows anyway he knows a lot he doesn't
know everything but he knows a lot yeah
he can't read our minds but yeah I I
think that he can probably have to six
thousand years of looking at people's
facial expressions
but taking these promises and praying
them out loud in the name of Jesus
is a protectant and that is Warfare
and you experienced that praying out
loud yeah I know as as Christians we
don't understand the power that we have
and we need to speak it
because his words are life speak his
words I think
um you know to make it a lot more
physical I anytime someone says
something about you know
seeing something or having some kind of
vision everyone's kind of like I don't
know you know what I mean so I
understand what you mean by you don't
want to say anything about it yeah
especially um in the spiritual
um
what's the word I'm looking for in other
occult religions you have
um something called astral projection
and obes yeah out of body experiences
and so you don't want to appear as if
you you are appearing uh seeing
something that's occultic but I do
believe that we need to um uh verbally
speak some things and I think that's
important because um not it's not even
though God knows our mind he can read
our minds he created us we there's a
there's a
a much bigger thing going on here
they're courts of Heaven they can't read
our minds and it's and and um
angels of God are standing close to us
and so they even though we might they
might be commissioned to say hey I want
to help this guy out
um just simply stating hey which side I
am on
um
Jesus said get thee behind me Satan he
didn't say I'm going to think about uh
getting taken behind me you know so
there is power and word and it's not
that we have the power but that Christ
has the power in US yeah and you got to
see
um behind the scenes of the real battle
I know and those angels are around us
both camps all the time yeah and so
speaking the word singing singing hymns
singing scripture Satan please yeah
that's a double blessing when we read
the word uh aloud because we hear it and
we speak it so
I think we need to spend more time but I
think another good topic would be
speaking the word
versus manifesting
because you hear so much about
manifesting these days so there is a
difference
did you feel
um
any different between contemplative
prayer and like when you really started
praying like
to God I always felt something when I
did contemplative prayer it always felt
good
when I pray today
um I don't always feel
but that's where we have to go back to
the Bible it says I will never leave you
nor forsake you
right and he says I have given you the
Holy Spirit we just have to thank him
for it ask him and thank him and so just
because I don't feel anything
doesn't mean that I don't have
the Holy Spirit or God in my life and I
think that
though I appreciate the times I might
have some
feeling experience as validation it's
not what we hang our hats on and we're
walking into a time when
it's going to be difficult yeah and the
the Warfare is going to become more
pronounced and so I may not always feel
good
you know because of what's happening
around me or to me but I'm learning now
that I don't need to worry then just
because I don't feel something that
God's not with me yeah so it's building
my faith in not feeling something all
the time yeah and I think that's really
important especially
like in today's culture because
especially when when you're in the New
Age too it's really hard to come out of
it because it feels so good and it's
like when you're experiencing these
feelings
um like who can judge your experience
really and so for someone to tell you oh
that's not real or that's a deception it
becomes really hard because it's like
you know I was there when you know X Y
and Z happened and I know how it feels
um because I know for me personally like
when I was in New Age I felt very
I don't it just felt like you're a baby
Christian just constantly like you just
feel like your prayers get answered and
um you just feel Fearless you feel like
connected to everything
um and then it wasn't until I came out
of that that I started having more
anxiety and like I just I felt super
Fearless in new ways like I feel like I
could do anything and I just had more of
like a explorative spirit and then when
I came to Christ I just had like anxiety
all the time everything and I used to
think
that was a bad thing and then I realized
that I like my anxiety I just I just
allow it to push me to God and so it's
like then I have to rely on him I have
to claim his scripture and his word and
things like that because you know it's
not the same spirit that I had before
but it was really hard for me to get out
of because you no one wants to feel
anxious about everything if if if God
can heal if Jesus can heal then why am I
as a Christian experiencing anxiety
right you know it's we are to be in the
world but not of the world
and there are consequences of sin so not
everything is going to be Rosy all the
time that's for heaven
so it's it's real yeah and you'll be
able to connect with people who have
that and give them hope and
encouragement yeah yeah there's
definitely an attack anytime you do come
out of yeah New Age there are people
who've had um who've done
counterfeit healings like through
traditional Chinese medicine or some
alternative healing that's not biblical
and they're healed yeah and then when
they find out what they
you know the spirit behind the healing
then they renounce that spirit and asked
for forgiveness their their aches and
pains come back do they have the faith
to walk it out you know and trust God
yeah
and those are things that can pull you
back into
um I actually remember one time I was at
this flea market
um back home and there was this there
were two different new agey people
there's the ones who have the Bible
verses out in front of their shops and
it's like oh yeah God made the Earth and
he made all these stones and they can
heal you and she was like where's this
this was everywhere yeah it's everywhere
but
um she had a beautiful shop it had like
herbs everywhere crystal stones oh it
was so beautiful and I went every Sunday
I bought some stones for my friends
um and then there was another one that
was more dark
and what I was particularly looking for
in that season of my life and new age
was amethyst stones and
um the lady that I usually would go to
had the Bible verses out there she
didn't have like the bracelets and so I
would I went to this other store and
that one had like
skulls and all these other things but
for me I was like I mean it's just a
stone and I've even asked friends and
they would tell me they would say like
oh yeah God made Stones like it's not
that big of a deal you know like and so
I never understood that there's Powers
Behind these things that people can pray
over them and so when I was going to buy
this amethyst Stone I remember I picked
it up and as I was about to give her my
money I just had like you know that
feeling when you're
um when the plane is taking off and your
ears just kind of like it like there's
just a lot of pressure and it was just
enough for me to drop it like to drop
everything and then I just walked out
and then I just had this
I guess you can say it's the holy spirit
it's just like you know and so I just
started looking up I just pulled out my
phone and Googled what does the Bible
say about crystal stones or something
like that and there was this one verse
that came up I don't remember where it's
from but it said like don't pay
attention to people who play with magic
stones or Witchcraft and things like
that across the street was a bookstore
and I and this was around a time too
where I was
slowly getting into witchcraft because I
was told it was good and it was healing
and I had also seen this demonstrating
TV yeah exactly like you're using it to
help people and to heal you yeah and I
am someone who loves natural remedies
and all these type of things so it was
right up my alley there's a deception
for everyone yes but I went across the
street and I remember um there was this
bookstore and I love bookstores too
um and what's sad about these bookstores
is they also sell the same things like I
don't know if you ever walked into
Books-A-Million or Barnes and Noble and
it's just witchcraft everywhere now but
I remember I went to the religion
section because I wanted to learn more
about New Age
um and to me it seemed like a religion
well it is that includes Christianity
and all those type of things so it
wasn't something that I saw as a cult it
was just another religion and it was
more unified and that was really
beautiful to me and so I couldn't find
anything when I was in the religion
section so I saw the one of the store
workers walking by and I asked him it's
like hey do you know where I can find
anything on crystal healing he said yeah
I'll go to the new age section so I go
to the new age section and I'm seeing
I'm walking by and I'm seeing dream
interpretation spells Satanic Bible and
then Crystal healing
and that was I was like what in the
world why is the Satanic Bible here
right you know and it was just it was
all in the same section and it was just
like just all the occult stuff packaged
together and I just remember just going
home that day and I was like man and it
took a while to get out of because it's
like you have to awaken from that stuff
but it was really eye-opening for me
because I was like why is this attached
to the Satanic Bible and I had people in
my life tell me God made these films
which is true God did me but not for
those purposes right but yeah exactly
they're not for healing like they don't
have these special powers
um and yeah I a few years down the line
I ended up throwing out throwing out all
those stones they were hard I gave them
to friends though I don't know if they
still have them throw them away but if
you're watching this yeah you're
listening please throw those away I've
always gone to those mom and pop shops
and like oh it's a pretty Stone I like
this one you know I don't think ever
bought one but um I I
think there has to be some Rules of
Engagement involved in this because if
some kid somewhere picks up and says hey
Mom I want this Stone
I don't know I I admit I don't know
everything about this I don't think any
of us really do but it's um there has to
be something that is very protectant of
the child that doesn't know anything
versus the person that's in there to buy
it for healing yeah
well let me say this okay okay all right
I have someone I know who was given
something
and she didn't know anything about it
she's not into crystals she's not into
this stuff but these relics were in her
house
and she reached out to me this time I'm
having sores and things on my body that
the doctor can't fix
and I'm like okay oh and a clock had
fallen off of a wall and a big clock
right where her head was she just
stepped gotten up and the clock fell
um the nail was still there big nail all
right I'm like go through your house
prayerfully go through your house and
look for anything
with symbols on it anything that um may
be related to movies
DVDs you know songs bands anything
and uh and just get it get rid of it
from your house she sent me a picture of
a a cross
um a glass cross
with Raw on it raw yes oh my goodness
yes
so she found that yes and she had a
mosque that someone had given her from
their travels to India or wherever they
would travel to and it was it was
beautiful handmade mosque but it had all
the symbols on it right I'm like they
have to go get them outside the house
she woke up the next morning nothing on
her body no problem since clock's still
on the wall that's crazy so whether we
realize it or not there's attachments
and that's what we have to look at
interesting yeah yeah sorry I mean I do
I do I do believe that there were
it is biblical because God said hey
satan you can only stay at this tree
he's you know you are this is where
you're
you are allowed to hang out and so and
then we told hey no Don't Go Near that
thing
um and so
maybe there's something to it I don't
think I think we see through glass
Darkly right now but man it's
it sure is confusing that's really weird
and Satan likes to keep things confused
right yeah so we just have to be
prayerful and careful and you know
research everything yeah and there's
forgiveness too I mean we do plot along
sometimes and get involved or given
something that we don't know about but
when we find out about it for sure yeah
then we have to get rid of it yeah and
God does there is level of protection
there and God does step in because I
mean I didn't take the stones home right
like I had that whole experience and
which is weird because I know like yeah
we talk about Rules of Engagement but I
also and maybe too this has to do with
other people's prayers for me because
there were times where I wasn't huge on
prayer during that time
um but I still felt like God was
like doing things without me asking
um and of course later you find out
that's your family's prayers or your
parents prayers but it just shows how
important prayer is
um but what's crazy about what you said
was of how her sores went away and it's
so interesting because in New Age and
occult practices
it's like this deception that there's
good spirits and bad spirits but they're
all in the same team and it's like
people will have all these protective
necklaces and things like that to
protect you from evil spirits and
they're literally the same spirits and
it's just crazy how there's this
constant back and forth of okay I'm
Healed from this but I'm sick and so I
need to get deeper into this occult
practice in order to like solve it we're
told that Satan causes illness and then
he can he brings in the healing yeah
yeah so he likes to play tricks with us
he does yeah yeah so some of my
practices in spiritual formation
um definitely contemplative prayer I
walk the Labyrinth which if you look at
the design of it it's basically geomancy
divination by shapes
um it it does something to the brain
it's a contemplative practice it takes
your mind offline it's left it's right
brain rather than left brain like a real
maze with multiple doors and you got
remember Amaze is one way in one way out
so you don't think about it is lectio
Divina which is divine reading or sacred
reading of the Bible
so it has the appearance of being
biblical and reading your Bible but it's
not so what lectio Divina is and we we
did this in spiritual formation all the
time it was a practice I didn't do it
but it was practiced a lot I could lead
you all through this but you would take
they always encourage a small passage
right so you just Shrunk the scriptures
um one or two verses you read the verses
out loud three times
you emphasize different words each time
you read it and after the third time you
consider what word or words popped up
for me that that resonated with me and
then
you take those words or word into your
contemplative prayer to see what God has
to say to you about that now we've
already established that that's another
Spirit speaking to you when you're oh
here's important when you're in
contemplative prayer
your brains go from beta which we are in
now thinking Discerning
um to Alpha brain waves our minds are
offline the morisha scans showed
decrease blood flow that's where the
Holy Spirit speaks to us so we shut the
door on the Holy Spirit we've opened
ourselves up to other Spirits other
beings as Alice a Bailey says when we
are
meditating than beings from past present
and future can drop thoughts into our
minds we know those beings are demonic
right they are not other people who've
lived in the past
so
I I in this where was I going to so in
this um way of
in this brainwave pattern there's only
one Spirit that's going to speak to us
so we have just extracted a word or two
from the scripture when we're supposed
to study line upon line precept upon
precept right compare scripture to
scripture
you can't take the word of God out of
context and think you're going to
understand what God is wanting to tell
you when it's another Spirit by the way
so that's how the real the word of God
gets Rewritten from my experience from
what God tells me in my prayer time and
we should not be teaching other people
to do this this is dangerous
and so
um
I just want to get that out there
because it's really coming to the
Forefront from
solid Ministries
right now and and misapplied in terms of
support spiritual support you know from
leaders but
um outside of that contemplation oh and
then I had
a Sacred Space that's another thing
Sacred Space uh it was just a little
table that was by my bed and I had my
singing bowl on it I would use my still
seeing ball my little hand lab handheld
Labyrinth and a candle always a candle
and whatever artifact like if I had been
if I'd written a poem If I Had something
some object that was meaningful to me I
put in my prayer space that's my
offering to you today Lord what do you
have to say to me about that
um
but Sacred Space in in witchcraft there
are two sacred spaces there's one to
protect the person
um and then there's one for divining so
if I'm going to
raise a spirit
then it's for that or if I'm going to
practice magic in some other form I'm
going to put that Circle of protection
around me so the Sacred Space the
spiritual information talks about is
rooted and grounded in the occult and
witchcraft
um
and yet we have authors Christian
authors like Mark Madison who wrote The
Circle Maker yeah and then we have other
denominations
um
who read these books and then bring them
to the Forefront and teach their their
congregation to pray circles around
you know I can just draw a circle and
that that releases God's power to work
on your behalf I'm praying for you that
is just so these these things you people
wonder how in the world does she get
into this I would never do that
here's how you do it compromise not
knowing the word of God well enough to
stand on the word of God and then having
a trusted person bring it to you your
pastor your youth leader whoever someone
you trust bringing you these practices
oh this is going to bring you closer to
God
and yet we are told
that your faith should not stand in the
wisdom of men but in the power of God
you know we we have to stick with this
and these ancient forms of doing things
are not from God yeah I think that's
powerful because I think what we see a
lot now especially with social media and
all these big name pastors people aren't
studying the word for themselves it's
read everybody else's opinion on
scripture but you know never actually
dig into it yourself and it's almost
like a weird way of saying we need
somebody to intercede between us and
Christ and he gives us the word you know
right there in front of us
and it's almost gone as if you if you
scream the loudest and you must be
correct right or who if you come up with
the most
um like these unique ideas that no one
has ever thought about you know it's
yeah it's crazy and all it takes for
these pastors just a little bit of pride
exactly and then it's it's over and yeah
and going outside
um the light we've been given we have
the Bible and we have Spirit of Prophecy
we don't need anything else Ellen White
says don't open the lid of another book
she also said Spirits accompany these
books these they're mesmerizing
and then we introduce them to our people
there was something else I was gonna say
oh
um the one thing that people keep
telling me
as they roll their eyes
why throw out the baby with the bath
water
okay somebody did give me a different
version
eat the watermelon spit the seeds yes
I've never heard that before and that
came from someone I respect yeah but
uh you cannot you cannot have your feet
planted into camps and it's confusion if
we're going to be calling people out of
confusion
then you know with the Three Angels
messages
then we can't give them confusion and
say come out of it this is a Catholic
author this is a great book you should
read this practicing the presents
um you know Brendan Manning this book
gets put out into churches and brought
forward in Prophecy seminars you should
read this book
you know and yet oh the Beast you know
we have to come out
but read this book it's confusing
we can't look to man and that's why we
need the Holy Spirit each of us
you mentioned something about sonic
stick
oh the stick did you read my book
it was like a little minor thing
um
in uh spiritual formation some of the
exercises one of them
um was called The Talking Stick
I mean it just sounds woo-woo right but
whoever has the stick can talk and you
just say whatever you feel impressed to
say and it gets passed around I know I
had to learn this in class wow I never
touched it again
[Laughter]
so yeah you passed the stick and it's a
very contemplative exercise so you're in
this like contemplative mindset and then
uh whatever God tells you then you say
and it's like okay how does it connect
when we've all said our thing what does
that mean what does it connect
is woo-woo but when I found out later
after I come out of this witches do the
same thing in their cousins do they
really yeah there's nothing new Under
the Sun all of this stuff is repackaged
and given the Christian veneer guys yeah
yeah and Alice a Bailey says
um
it's a long quote and I can't remember
it verbatim but she says then basically
the new religion
will have the Christian lingo it will
appear to be but inside it'll have it'll
have its exterior trappings but inside
it'll be different and we're seeing that
with the emerging Church
vocabulary sounds really close to what
we're used to as Christians but it
doesn't mean the same thing like
missional versus Mission or missionary
Mission all this means we're social
justice we do programs to make people's
lives better around the community
versus going to another country or
something like that to proselytize
we don't teach prophecy
um as a missional church we just help
make a difference in their life
except on where they are and then
Kingdom you know kingdom is right here
right now not where we're going to be
going even though Jesus lives in our
hearts
so it's very and expand the kingdom by
accepting and embracing except an
embrace
so it's very it like like Bailey has
accomplished uh what she set out to do
and we know the spirit that was driving
her so this is why the churches look
different this is why things like this
are coming in
so when I came out of this in 2012 fully
I thought I was free and clear and under
the radar and then in 2016
God had me
um
write my testimony
so not only did I have to share it but
the world right but there was a reason
as someone who was delving into this I
was going to become a spiritual director
and bring it into my my denomination
because we needed this right because
everything was trying boring we needed
love
right and so there's this
there's this tension that we have to
really find a balance to love and works
or love and law you know and so I had
experienced the law
um
and then I experienced love and
spiritual formation
but coming out of error
and so anyway I had to I had to
re-experience or relearn what love is
it's sacrificing right Jesus sacrificed
for me and so as I reworked that
um and my relationship with him became
living again then that's where God's
love is so as I was coming coming out of
this and ruin the research of the book
that's when I started to see how
spiritual formation fit into the
emerging church and how all these pieces
are rooted and grounded in the occult in
Witchcraft and today when I talk about
these things
they most people like me they didn't get
it they're like what are you talking
about that didn't make any sense they
don't see the connection you have to
study this you do the Bible says study
and show yourself approved
so and for lack of knowledge people are
lost knowledge doesn't save us but you
know
um it helps our footing in writing my
book it was the very last
um piece of it and
it was sent to a different editor at
that point Remnant had taken it over and
they were going to use an editor but
they were all busy so they they brought
in they contracted one for this book and
I had kept this book really close only
with trusted people I knew because of
the content
when I got that book back the manuscript
back everything that I teased apart
to parent to compare and contrast
got re-blended it was all confusion
and yet this person said they didn't
know anything about this topic well
somebody some Spirit knew because it
Blended again but this is the attack
and when this book goes into you know
the little mail not mailboxes but the
like the ministry magazine or the
catalogs they're a little they're like
these uh metal boxes that people kind of
support and they'll put literature in
there
and there there's a gentleman who has
included now my book he says Steph nine
times out of ten I go back to that that
dispensing machine and whatever it's
free
and he says your book cover is ripped
off it's torn up in some way it's marked
through and he says there's an attack on
this book so you can't tell me that
Satan's not
please you know he's not happy about
what's being exposed that is occult and
demonic
um so to me that's just more validation
of what I'm finding and I'm not the only
one who's found these roots you know
where it's consistent with other people
who do the research so
um yeah we are dealing with with real
spiritual issues
whether we realize it or not
uh would you like to share your uh with
our audience uh maybe somebody out there
is going through maybe the same thing
you're going through or maybe they know
somebody that they maybe they're doing
contemplating player and maybe in their
cold or something like that maybe you
need to look at the camera and just talk
to them maybe you you find out thoughts
or something you want to share okay so
if there is anybody out there if you are
practicing these practices or even just
one of these practices uh really
pray about what you're doing and do a
deeper deeper dive don't just trust
information that someone has given you
the ultimate
person we need to look at is God and
what he says and we have his word
um I failed for not taking him seriously
in his word and studying deeper
and I missed a lot
and I don't want that for you so
um
don't look at people
look at the Bible and compare what
you're doing with what he says and it
may not feel good
but if you obey him the blessings will
far outweigh and your life will never be
the same
Stephanie thank you so much for coming
on the program today that was a
fascinating journey through your life
and your this journey is is only begun
because God has an amazing amazing
future for you and how you're presenting
this information to other people and we
really appreciate it praise God thank
you where can people find your uh your
your material right there so s
griffin.org if you want to look for me
on YouTube Stephanie Griffin Ministries
I'm sometimes with these guys it's kind
of fun and uh Facebook Stephanie Griffin
Ministries as well as Instagram and you
can contact me through my website would
love to hear from you and also you have
a documentaries coming right oh yeah
mystified yeah mystifiedfilm.com go
check it out should be out well I'm not
gonna say because there's so much going
in there but it's getting really close
thank you all for uh joining the program
today hit that like button hit that
share button and share it with someone
that you know and comment tell us what
you think about it also if you like the
program if you want to get some merch go
to lightweird.shop check out some of our
merch on there and uh yeah I'm sure
you're gonna like that and also in
patreon and follow us on patreon and
support uh our ministry to become a
patreon
and if you would like to donate you can
do so through our website at lls.tv give
thank you guys
bye
thank you
[Music]
foreign
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you